we were talking about soros for a minute
okay oh we got the story from the daily
mail magnificent mile no more chicago is
blighted by shoplifting as another
american city goes down the toilet
because it's left wing ag stops
prosecuting shoplifters who steal less
than 1 000 of goods this again it's a
viral video of people and so the mag
mile for no chicago is this like strip
of you know just
really nice shops it's like touristy
yeah it's touristy yeah i don't know
michigan avenue yeah michigan
and uh they've got their you know
forever 21 and gucci whatever but
there's a video of these people running
in and just like young men stealing a
bunch of stuff and then running out it's
very very um it's very it's so
progressive san francisco it's so
progressive i just i just love the idea
that um seemingly like as if it's
coordinated another city says anything
under a thousand bucks we will not
prosecute what do you think happens when
you're like bro
if you come out you say um ladies and
gentlemen marijuana position is now
decriminalized 30 grams or less or
whatever they did whatever state and
then people are going to be like okay
and they'll go get some and then when
you're like we're also going to have 36
grams i'm good decriminalizing
stealing stuff under a thousand bucks
they're gonna be like all right they're
gonna walk in and they're gonna they're
gonna hold their bag and they're gonna
scan every item and it's 991.99
they're gonna they're gonna have a bag
of groceries yeah scan it at the self
checkout it'll say 899.99 and they'll go
thank you and they'll walk out without
without paying you good and the police
officers don't even want to respond to
any of these calls we were talking about
this with michael what was the name
schallenberger
burger yesterday since he worked with uh
soros of course so so this is something
that soros has been making he was a
soros guy huge yeah a huge a huge impact
on when it comes to setting policies
that directly affect people now when you
look at storefronts that are affected
it's not just the big box stores it's
also middle class it's also small
businesses that are affected here
there's a big conspiracy online saying
that a lot of the big billionaires are
actually financing this so everything
goes digital and and real stores are
kind of thrown and kicked out of
existence and already there was kind of
this retail apocalypse that we were
seeing just a few years ago because of
the internet that started this
apocalypse has been made worse but when
these laws are implemented and stores
are barren because people are just
gathering their friends coming in there
10 deep 20 deep and just taking whatever
they want
as long as it's under a thousand dollars
and able to get away with it what is
that going to lead that's going to lead
a lot of these stores not being open
everything to be more digitized so
there's a theory going around that this
is even bigger and that george soros and
other people are involved here in order
to push this retail apocalypse now again
that's a lot of assertions but uh in our
mind nothing and you will be exactly
you'll have no body and you'll be happy
and then you also have a war on cash
that way because when you have a war on
retail you have a war on kind of free
enterprise people being able to exchange
goods with cash anonymously uh instead
of just having everything track traced
in database online wouldn't you want to
be plugged into your own personal matrix
the metaverse excuse me it's called that
mark zuckerberg calls it the well listen
listen you look outside your window in
chicago and what do you see
crime
gun battles gangs and you say to
yourself i am going to plug into the
oasis mark zuckerberg's metaverse that's
ready player one the oasis right yeah
right yeah see ready player one was
transhumanist propaganda because they
want you to think it'll be like the
oasis oh it'll be this cool video game
and we get to
you know all play it'll be like all our
favorite games and movies and this whole
john hughes thing i read the book too i
read even
ready player two i like the books but
that's not what it's going to be like
right because it's going to be like
remember he lives in a trailer park this
giant trailer park that's going to the
stacks that's going to be the whole
world they kill his family they kill his
mom
yeah they crush her and so and there's
like there's like this corporate drone
strike that like takes her out and his
entire neighborhood that's going to be
the world and then you're not going to
be someone who has like a physical
you know uh self other than some like
corpulent
ball of goo
right you're gonna be like in wall-e
right now you know sure in the real like
have you seen surrogates yeah so it's
for those of my circuits of the movie
where everyone has a robot version of
themselves but like in the beginning
this like two people uh mean it's like a
hot chick and a guy and then they try to
track they get murdered because it's a
device can kill them through the
surrogate surrogates are basically
robots that you you control from your
house for safety reasons and then they
track this guy the woman down turns out
it's a big morbidly obese man right
using a woman body so a lot of this
people think they're going to live in
this digital virtual world where they
will be
what you know whatever their whatever
self-identified person is or you know
but if you actually think about it
whenever it comes to
these authoritarian ideologies
the low the low-ranking individuals who
foment it by you know protesting or
rioting or demanding it think there's
going to be some beautiful new world
it's going to be we're going to have all
this free stuff i love that meme right
where the guy said what do you what are
you going to do once communism is
established and then he's like i'll
probably take some art classes hang out
with my friends do some farm classes on
my farm and then maybe go to the store
and then someone's like your father
hilarious these people don't get it
hilarious no i actually saw a good one
i saw a twist on that actually
version where they were saying it no no
it was one where they were saying uh uh
so what do you want to do in the new
world and it was like a woman and they
go oh well you know just like kind of
raise my family take care of my kids
maybe do some gardening
you know sort of hang out read write
write in poetry and they said so you
want to be a trad wife yeah yeah
they're like your kids yeah your kids
our kids the villagers i saw a similar
meme of an npc being like during
communism i'm going to write poetry and
study
and practice my slam poetry and then uh
it's another npc with a machine gun in
the next frame saying off to the gloom
the better one is it's a cry it's a guy
with glasses and like a hipster haircut
and it's green and he's crying and he
said there must be some mistake i'm i'm
a web blogger i should be writing
stories and the guy pointing the gun
says shut up and break the rocks
that's the future there must be some
mistake i supported all of this
there's a reason we don't talk about the
mensheviks anymore to be fair though if
they do this metaverse thing where they
want you to spend most of your life in a
digital world controlled by mark
zuckerberg sure they're the the the
problem isn't going to it's gonna be
brave new world it's not gonna be this
like it's not gonna be a digital gulag
it's going to be a digital pleasure
exactly yeah they're going to they're
going to be giving you all the great
things you want and if you defy them
they take those things away from you
you'll be getting paid to eat digital
food instead of real food like if you're
hungry they'll be like eat this digital
broccoli for a token and then you'll do
it you want to watch it you'll skip a
meal because it'll be hard to get food
to people so that this will be ways to
if they can if they can do true
what and then you get like a dose of
nutrients in the real world
like injectable nutrient paste or
something i just picked up an msn a
business insider article jack dorsey
mocks zuckerberg's metaverse plan saying
it's dystopian
oh really
i think jack's more legit than people
give him credit for but he's not in a
position but that's my point billionaire
oh yeah that he just how much money did
he give away to like social justice
causes spare me but dude's a coward i
mean regarding twitter he's not a
position with twitter to do anything
with twitter anymore he sold the company
basically yeah but he could buy up large
portions of it back he's got square and
he's working with bitcoin he doesn't
care dude
i've heard he could get in the fight i
have unknown enough from him he's
speaking out no no no no no no no
zuckerberg's uh i don't know i've heard
so much from this guy about what he was
planning to do for the past several
years he never does well some of you do
what happens is he says i'm gonna make a
social media platform that's crypto
based on the blockchain so you can't ban
people and then he does nothing but when
he says it everyone's like oh look at
jack dorsey so now he comes out and he's
like mark zuckerberg's dystopian and
people are like oh yeah jack dorsey shop
he's not doing this see this is how i
feel about john stewart that's exactly
well
i think i agree with you by the way i
feel the same way about elon musk
is threatening to walk away from his
entire syndicated well it's just words i
mean we're all talking about people just
talking right now i still think
zuckerberg bannon's not steve bannon was
like shove it yeah and they're like
we're gonna wrestle
let me let me let me and i'll you know
just because i've actually read the
um the legal filings from bannon's
lawyers and from his team and like he
and i haven't discussed this or anything
even though you know i you know i
co-host on war room a lot um so i've had
like ton of people hitting me up oh
what's eve gonna do with you it's right
there in the file links he's pointed out
that he did testify for in front of
mueller he did go to the senate he did
go to the house he's testified three
separate occasions and he actually says
that he'd be happy to testify again but
the floor vote's not gonna they want to
ask him about well this is the legal
side he wants to they want to ask him
about his conversations with trump and
the thing is
when he had those conversations with
trump this is prior to january 20th that
means trump was the sitting president of
the united states executive person
that's under executive privilege this
the house which is part of congress is
part of the legislative branch and it's
and the supreme court has held this for
a long time that those branches that
this is a check against right but jack
laws don't matter you no no no you run
an empire look what they did to michael
flynn look what they did to so many
other people that stood in their way
they took them down i still believe
dorsey and zuckerberg are just front
people in my personal opinion a part of
the larger kind of agenda that they're
pushing well the larger agenda is esgs
from blackrock and then essentially
giving an esg is a corporate social
credit score so blackrock has the money
because they've been given these loans
they can get it directly from the fed
through the cantillian effect right
you're getting their get they're not
seeing the inflation on their end but
then if anybody else wants the
investment if anybody else wants to
boost their stocks through blackrock
buying whatever percentage they're
buying of you you know do they have
seven percent of pfizer today four
percent of fighters say it fluctuates um
i was actually talking to a guy about
this and he he owns a utilities company
in pennsylvania and he was saying like
blackrock has been buying and selling
our stock for years and they won't even
talk to us like we've tried to reach out
to them and they won't even get on the
phone with us and they'll be spending
millions and millions of dollars because
of this
you